et
[Musique]
après la terrible guerre contre gênes et
sa terre presque tous les shadoks ont
disparu il ne reste sur la lune que
quatre rescapés que vous connaissez ce
jour là encore une voix les shadoks se
retrouvèrent houdoud incroyable effort
de souffrances et de sacrifices
là d'où ils étaient partis c'est à dire
pratiquement nulle part car on ne peut
pas dire que la lune soit un quelque
part est leur seul espoir somme c'était
de savoir que d'autres efforts d'autres
souffrances et d'autres sacrifices les
amèneraient évidemment au même endroit
mais il ne se plaignait pas car tel
était depuis toujours leur destinée il
venait de nulle part et c'est là qu'ils
allaient mais il fallait quand même y
aller
ce jour là les shadoks ce contest il
restait en tout et pour tout sur la lune
un chef shadoks mois 1/2 un plombier un
vieux cosme autobus un professeur shadow
qu une pile de détritus et la population
que vous voyez rassemblés ici
elle n'était pas très très peuplée la
population elle n'était pas non plus
près autre regret le malheureux shadoks
population n'était malheureusement pas
comme on dit en possession de moyens
intellectuels parfaitement normaux
disons plutôt qu'il était en parfaite
possession de moyens intellectuels
exceptionnellement anormaux c'est lui
qu'on avait surnommé autrefois
l'irrécupérable c'est vous dire
il fut nommé ministre de la population
est aussitôt sommé de faire son devoir
de population qui est de pop les pondre
des oeufs pour les shadoks en principe
vous vous souvenez c'était facile
il suffisait de compter jusqu'à 4 mais
celui là malheureusement n'était pas
assez éduqué au début je comptais il
recommençait et ça donnait des yeux tout
à fait impropre à la population à la fin
quand même ils s'y étaient mis mais cela
me prenait tellement de temps un
repeuplement shadoks intensifs et massif
était totalement impossible n'est shadow
coup semblait avoir une idée
[Musique]